many european countries were some of the
worst hit by covid19 when it first swept
the world
last year the world health organization
says europe is now the epicenter
spain now has more deaths than china
europe's response to the pandemic and
the vaccine rollout
has been criticized for being
disorganized and slow
but would the outcome have been
different if europe had more female
leaders
i think you know out of the attributes
associated with leadership
to deal with the pandemic on 13 out of
19
women actually come ahead of men
christine lagarde president of the
european central bank
spoke to zany minton bedos the economist
editor-in-chief
about the long-term damage of covert 19
in europe
what do you see as the longer term
scarring consequences of this and i'm
thinking for example of a of
something that i know you have been very
concerned about long before the pandemic
which is the
widening of inequality that we've seen
around the world it's something you
raised the alarm on
when you were at the imf very very
effectively in so many ways this
pandemic has not just
exposed existing inequalities it's
worsened them um
how much does that worry you and and
frankly what do we need to do about it
i think it raises the question of what
kind of economy are we going to
um land in i don't want to say go back
to because i think that
the economy that we will land in uh
are that will we will that will have
morphed into
when the pandemic is always going to be
different from what what we've
experienced
pre-pandemic so i think the way in which
we we
we buy we pay uh we learn we
look after our health will be different
and probably uh probably for good so
that's one of the uh
the good outcome if you will of the
transformation that we are seeing now if
you look at
the not so positive outcome clearly
there has been
a worsening of inequalities and
while this is not for a central bank to
actually address
and try to find the policies that will
respond to the inequalities
i think it will be upon governments to
identify the set of polities
policies that will best respond to
closing
reducing addressing those inequalities
it won't surprise you but i will mention
women
as those that have actually heavily
suffered from
the worsened inequalities
caused by the pandemic particularly
because of the uh
you know the gray the grey work or the
uh the informal
work which is predominantly done by
women and which are the first
uh to go in in situations that we're
going through at the moment
but if you look at the proportion of
women that are a
victim of the current um
furlough schemes often followed by
layoff
women are taking a much heavier burden
than men
it's it's really documented now very
clearly
if you look at the proportion of men and
women who are working
in those industries particularly the
service industries that are subject to
social
distancing and as a result are being hit
first predominantly women
you know you look at hospitality you
look at all those things
and if you look at those that are most
exposed to the pandemic
at the lower end of the scale in the
health sector in particular
you have many more women than men there
is a there's a kind of
i think interesting debate going on
right now and that countries which had
female leaders have done better in the
pandemic
um now we can discuss whether that to
what degree is true but certainly there
is
an argument that many are making that
that's true and you famously said if it
had been lehman sisters rather than
lehman brothers the world look would
look very different after the financial
crisis
you know is there something um about
female leadership that is different
would we have been better off if more
countries have been led by women during
this pandemic
there's been a harvard study that was
just recently published
it's an analysis of the perception that
people have had
of the way in which the crisis was
managed and there is an overwhelming
response
that shows again its perception that
people have had
that shows that they feel that women had
had a better way
to deal with the pandemic i think you
know out of the 19
attributes associated with leadership to
deal with the pandemic
on 13 out of 19 women actually come
ahead of men now is that to say that
they have done a fabulous job probably
not
uh is it to say that they had attributes
such as empathy such as appreciating the
fear that people had
such as reaching out that that was um
you know dominant in their way of
dealing with the crisis
probably so there are so fewer women
than men
actually in charge of those issues that
the fact that
many of them have been successful is
also an indication that
they're pretty damn good so what do you
then do to get more women
into those positions to have more women
in leadership organizing
you know pipes into which women are
supported or trained
or experienced are given role models
uh during that period of time when you
combine
learning jobs and and pushing yourself
as well as having children significant
you know on on-site support and and
you know financed
support made available and at the end of
the day
honestly targets or quotas depending on
how you know
what is the level of tolerance of the
organizations or the institutions
but simply saying okay if i have the
choice between
at the same quality level and training
between a man and a woman
if i have 20 women and 80 man i will
pick the woman
and i look at back 10 years ago when i
was
i was finance minister there was a law
that was pushed in french parliament
that required that
ultimately 40 of board members in all
french public companies should be women
10 years later they just celebrated the
anniversary of this law
it is now the case 40 of public
companies in france board members are
female so to anybody who says oh
terribly sorry they are not enough
competent female
oh not true if you have to find them you
find them europe is going to have
you know much less fiscal stimulus and i
think you've actually spoken about that
in the past
than than might have been anticipated so
you know isn't it disappointing in in
the recent past what has happened and
perhaps more importantly what will the
knock-on effect
of that be on the european economic
outlook it looks now as though europe's
going to have a slower weaker recovery
certainly than the one anticipated in
america and the fiscal response was
weaker in europe
than it was in in america that's for
sure the automatic stabilizers in europe
are
much larger stronger and provide better
welfare and coverage than what exists in
most american
states because a lot of those welfare
benefits are actually handled at state
levels
um so you we're really talking about
different economies but it is a fact
that um both member states and
and europe at large should continue to
provide
fiscal support uh to our economies
uh at least throughout 2021 and probably
beyond depending on
you know how the pandemic affects our
economy how the vaccination
uh process is rolled out how quickly
herd immunity is obtained
and how the race against the variance of
the virus
can be won by additional vaccinations or
by
you know additional therapies and how
our economies
actually transform now what is coming uh
in 21 is what was agreed
by the europeans and which is called
this pan-european next-generation eu
special funds hopefully will be spent
uh in the second half of 21 for the
first tranches that are due to
uh to to kick-start uh the investment
the focus on green the focus on digital
we have have gone digital the way we
live the way we work the way we shop the
way you and i are now communicating
has completely changed and i guess then
what is the consequence of that
for central banks has the pandemic shown
the world that it is time to make a
major switch
to digital trade and e-commerce and what
do you think the
banking landscape in particular looks
like in a digital age so
you know how how fast are you going to
change and to be very specific you know
when are you going to introduce a
digital currency at the ecb
i think more and more are convinced that
this is the way to go we should have a
digital currency which will not exclude
banknotes
we should have a digital currency that
is respectful
of privacy which is not selling data
which is not exploiting the data of
people that are using it
a digital currency that also uses the
canal of banks
because banks will be part and parcel in
that digital currency
uh launch and and then we will have to
you know refine it to the point that it
is completely safe
secure and can be used effectively with
less cost
more security as i said
respect for privacy of those that are
using it and on the voluntary basis
it's not to substitute existing
uh payment means so those who like
banknotes
um will continue to use their banknotes
but
those who want to use digital payments
should be able to do so
it's hard to say but i would say in the
next four years we should we should we
should be there
thank you christine lagarde lovely to
speak with you
i'm miranda johnson deputy executive
editor at the economist
if you'd like to read more of our
coverage on the coronavirus click on the
link
you can also listen to our new podcast
series about the global
vaccine rollout it's called the jab and
you can find it wherever you get your
podcasts
thanks for watching
you